in the home there was
108,000 excess deaths of which only
12,800 about 12% were down to coid that
can't be an Under reporting because
we're testing everybody on the death
certificat we're more likely to do it so
the story of this pandemic the
restrictions and everything we've done
is that there's been a huge excess death
in our own homes that n nearly 90% of it
is not down to coid so if we were going
to learn a lesson we'd start to break
down the data dive into it and go well
what's going on and then the government
would go let's investigate what's going
on and understand the drivers so we can
learn lessons and in doing so that's how
an inquiry would get to somewhere near
the truth but like you say is it doesn't
seem to want to go there